là il va devoir traverser
elle va devoir traverser un labyrinthe
il va jouer pour yann qui est au
téléphone avec nous qui est à lyon c'est
sayan un oui merci
vous êtes en famille non avec un peu
chez moi
d'accord il s'appelle comment lucas
d'accord merci ça va vous fait quoi au
bois qui t'a fait rôle
d'accord pas tout dit j'espère pas tout
nu j'espère que vous allez jouer avec
bertrand chamerois je vous explique un
petit peu les règles du jeu et d'avoir
deux minutes pour trouver le sushi d'or
ils jouent pour yann il y aura tout à
l'heure thierry moreau qui va y aller
également donc on le fait sortir
si thierry moreau est plus rapide que
yann et que bertrand
il fera gagner le voyage à quelqu'un
d'autre mais déjà bertrand chamerois qui
sort du labyrinthe
yann je vous dis franchement j'y crois
mais qu'à moitié
bertrand vous allez y aller vous allez
de jouer le soulier d'or se trouve à la
fin du labyrinthe voulait dire un mois
yann bertrand yann d'avant ce pardon je
vais faire mon maximum et ne m'en veut
pas quoi allez on joue pour un voyage au
japon pour deux personnes pour yann
c'est parti deux minutes on y va
c'est quoi
je sais pas mais je me suis cassé la
gueule comme une merde [ __ ] non droit
qu'est ses revenus les potes fait plutôt
cette réalisation qu'on le voit comme ça
pas la caméra sur des records s'il vous
plaît merci bolivar la vache de ménage
jeu je vous déteste tous autant que vous
êtes sauf les chroniqueurs en plateau et
moi et moi et on en reparle après la
sortie du nadia ajjan [ __ ] elle est de
retour là que la folle du truc là non
retourner en arrière sinon calme toi
mais en sort de commandes de ce hdd a du
coup vu tes potes et toi tu étais toi tu
es taf a put mais c'est quoi cette merde
jeunes gens nés dans les crocos la sa
gries non mais dis moi l'amour fou
qu'est ce que vous faites alors [ __ ]
attention attention vers 39 ans nous la
droite le contrôle de leurs soucis dans
la salle juliette dans l'audace toile et
dans l'eau dont le attention marcoux
maintenant vous allez mettre sortir
matin sur les routes aux vigiles pas
[ __ ] mais la saga
la réponse
sylla
bertrand à viville 44 à nos braves au
meurtre merci nous rejoindra l'instant
il y avait une minute 44 thierry moreau
qui va essayer de faire mieux tout à
l'heure